[Music]
all right so uh we're gonna start the
afternoon session today uh so we're
gonna have three very exciting speakers
uh surya then alexander then soledad
um so first we will have soria gonzakar
from tti chicago
thanks jerry
thank you all for
coming for my talk and thanks to the
organizers for inviting me
so today
i'm going to talk about
how the optimization geometry affects
optimization bias i'll define what these
are uh in a minute but i have given some
version of this talk uh in quite a few
places in recent times i apologize for
anyone who is hearing it for
hearing it as a repeat performance and
especially in microsoft i think this is
the third time i'm giving
there is some of the results in this
dark
um so actually one point i wanted to
highlight especially in in this version
of the talk is although it doesn't
appear in the title i'm gonna talk a lot
about
how what we call as optimization bias
has a very different nature between
regression problems and classification
problems specifically when we use losses
like squared loss which is often used in
regression problems versus
logistic laws which is more commonly
used in classification problems so
my
friend and
colleague venom calls it a squared loss
versus logistic loss talk and
although it doesn't appear in the title
that will be one of the themes i'll
focus on today
uh
so um
i think we have heard enough deep
learning talks to know that the deep
learning deep networks used in practice
work in this very large network trained
on very large scale data sets and the
key component of uh
many neural net deep learning models is
some form of loss
loss minimization using some variance of
gradient descent so you have the
empirical loss over data sets and
you essentially do some stochastic
gradient descents and its variants on
this empirical laws to get the final
solution
and ah most neural networks used in
practice today are often work in this
over parameterized regime i think by now
i do not have to define over
parameterization
an easy definition to keep in mind is
the number of
parameters larger than the number of
examples in the data set but a more
functional
definition i will be working with is
that there are multiple functions which
minimize the empirical loss function so
these are settings where the empirical
loss has multiple global minimizers
and what makes this problem an imposed
problem from an optimization perspective
is not just that it has multiple
minimizers but these different
minimizers have different properties in
terms of the learning goal which we care
about which is how well we'll do on a
new example
and although like as the as optimization
problem they're all like all global
minimizers are equivalent but for the
learning problem which we really care
about different global minimizers have
different properties so a carbon picture
to keep in mind is like we have a
landscape with multiple minimizers
different
algorithms now
which which are used to optimize this
objective will take us to different
minimizers as a consequence they'll lead
us to different models so unlike
classical optimization where the
objective is well posed now we also have
to care about which algorithm we are
using to minimize this objective and now
the algorithm matters not just for
computational reasons but also for
learning related reasons to understand
what is the inductive bias which the
algorithm introduces into the system
so so this implicit inductive bias from
the algorithm into a learning problem is
what we call as optimization bias and a
big picture agenda for this entire line
of work is to ultimately understand what
is
variance of gradient design specifically
stochastic gradient descent ah converge
to in over parameterized learning models
in general over parameterized learning
models specifically our main motivating
uh
goal is to understand it in neural
networks
but in today's talk we are going to uh
today's talk and in the line of work we
have been willing we we have started
studying this problem from very basic
settings which is uh like
linear models most of the results
presented today will be
on linear models except for a few
towards the end which i'll allude to for
non-linear models
and
motivation for studying linear models is
this is a simple and natural starting
point where we can build analytical
tools to understand this new phenomenon
of optimization bias or at least it was
a new phenomenon when we started
studying it and we'll see that like even
in these linear function settings which
seems very simple we'll see many
interesting and surprising results and
which which give us some intuition of
what what are some of the generalizable
principles for more complex models
and finally uh something which i would
not have time to go into is that the the
the theoretical understanding we get
from linear models can often give us
intuitions or empirical guidelines in
terms of optimization algorithms for
neural networks too and here we don't
have very strong connections but some of
our papers explore how the insights from
the theoretical analysis we have for
linear models can be used
uh
shows
show some positive results in neural
network training too
so we'll start with the simplest linear
model we can think of which is least
squares problem so it's a linear
regression problem but except that it's
an underdetermined linear regression
problem so we have a least squares
objective but the number of data points
we have is much smaller than the number
of uh the dimension of the parameter we
are learning as a consequence there are
many solutions which perfectly fit the
data give zero error uh i mean
we are assuming there is some level of
non-region uh non-degeneracy so that
this system of equations has a solution
and in fact it has multiple solutions
and in this case we can ask what is
what happens if i run different
optimization algorithms on this
objective
and the first result will see that if
you do gradient descent on this
objective with initialization starting
at zero independent of step size and
some forms of momentum and
whether i do stochastic gradient
instance wise to cassicity or not you
will always converge your solution which
minimizes
the l2 norm of the parameters subject to
fitting the data
so it's a minimum l2 solution and more
generally if i start with general
initialization it's in a minimum l2
distance solution and this result is not
hard to see i mean once we write down
the update equations it is a pretty
simple proof which is we can write what
the update equations for this problem
are and we immediately see that the
gradients uh
for this objective are always spanned by
the data points so as a consequence your
updates never leave the space span of
the data and within the span of the data
there is a unique solution which happens
to be the solution so it's a pretty
simple two line proof but this is pretty
much the only section where there will
be a two line proof in this line of work
right
and
uh well this this result while uh
for those of you have not seen it might
seem something um somewhat surprising
and somewhat unsurprising because we say
gradient descent and euclidean norm
there is always like there is a
connection between them and the
connection comes through the what we
call as optimization geometry which is
uh we can think of gradient descent as
essentially an steepest descent
algorithm where you take a steepest
decision step and the step length is
like penalized in a euclidean nonsense
so it's in some sense the steepest
descent within a euclidean geometry
um or another more mathematically the
gradient descent update step can be
written in this um
as this arc minimization problem where
each update is penalized in the
euclidean norm this gives us
some ways to generalize this class of
algorithms in particular you can think
of steepest descent with respect to
general norms that leads to
a family of algorithms in particular
special case of the family is coordinate
descent which is
which we get when we do when the norm is
l1 norm
and
another family of algorithms is what we
get when instead of penalizing the uh
the updates in in some norm we penalize
it in bregman divergence
so the bregman divergence between the
next update and the current update and
that leads to a mirror descent family of
algorithms i'm not going to define
bregman divergence it's just i mean for
those of you not familiar with it it's
just some distance like measure which is
not necessarily a norm
ah
okay so uh our goal in one of our works
was to understand like uh what are the
different optimization biases which
arise from these different geometries in
particular can we wanted to understand
if even for simple problems can we
relate the optimization bias that is
which solution a specific algorithm
really reaches to the optimization
geometry which
uh by which we refer to the specific
norm or specific divergence in uh specif
in which the optimization updates take
place
and
for
we we first started by studying it in
the least squares problem and here we
could our first positive result was that
for mirror descent in fact we can get a
close characterization close form
characterization and we can show that
for any step size and instance wise
stochastic gradient descent the solution
will converge to a
specific uh specific global minimizer
which minimizes the bregman divergence
to the initialization
so this is this would have been a
natural guess from the gradient descent
result and this indeed holds true
and
generalizing this at least uh
aesthetically we would expect that for
steepest decent algorithm we would get
something like
will hope to get a solution which
minimizes the this corresponding
steepest distance norm or the distance
to the initialization in the street
position norm
ah but we can easily come up with
counter examples to show that actually
this does not happen ah in particular
this is a toy
empirical example where this blue line
is a set of global minimizers
so this black star is what we would get
by minimizing the steepest decent norm
and
we see that for different step sizes
actually like this these are the paths
traced out by the algorithm and
different step sizes you lead to
different will lead to different points
on on this
line
so one of the main differences is unlike
mirror descent or gradient design which
you previously studied for general norms
the solution can explicitly depend on
the step size used for this problem
and in particular even
some
interesting step size special cases of
step size like step size going to zero
we don't get conversions to the expected
characterization in the setting
so we see that like so far there is some
connection between like the geometry and
the updates and we see the connection
explicitly in mirror edison but we also
see that it's non-trivial in the sense
that it is it does not generalize to all
forms of uh staples descent
and with respect to the second result
there was in some sense we didn't expect
this to hold because there is a previous
result on epsilon boosting uh which is
which you can think of like uh
coordinate descent
infinitesimal coordinate descent path
and where it was shown that it matches
the regularization path only in the only
under some special
set of measurement measurements uh in
this case
so we didn't hope to have this as a
general result but we can also see this
for
not just l1 norm we can also see it for
other lp norms
where norm square is strongly convex
so so far we have looked at one type of
geometry and we see some positive some
mixed results in terms of how we can
relate to the optimization bias
ah so there is yet another way we can
introduce uh optimization geometry which
is through parameterization so think of
optimization problems where where the
optimization objective is over a class
of functions there are many ways we can
parameterize this class class of
functions for example if i think of just
linear functions in rd a standard
parameterization would be like take d d
d dimensional vector but you can also
parameterize a d dimensional vector as a
product of two d dimensional vectors or
a convolution between two d dimensional
vectors and in all of these cases under
if
if i replace an optimization objective
over w with like an optimization
objective over u and v the underlying
problem does not change
but i by changing the parameterization i
have changed the inherent geometry of
the updates in other words now if i take
the same algorithm on different
parameterizations
and look at trace the path of the
algorithm in the function space they
will look very different
and this is a cartoon picture borrowed
from nadi's talk like from yesterday
where
we have some parameter space and it maps
to some real function space we care
about and
for every path in the parameter space
there is a corresponding path in the
function space
let's say in parameter space we have
some simple biases that the optimization
algorithm will always converge in a
small ball
it can lead to much more complex biases
in the function space because of the
mapping
how the exact mapping goes about
okay
um so
so we we also wanted to study how the
geometry induced by parameters affect
our ah results and
going back to the same least squares
problem for one last time ah we
initially saw how if i did gradient
descent on the standard least squares
objective we get minimum euclidean
solution
and in a follow-up work actually a
corollary of it we corollary of our
in one of our work we studied what
happens if i do this product
parameterization for the vectors and in
this case we can say that um
we can quantifiably say that uh with
infinitesimal step size and
infinitesimal initialization so these
are like very special step sizes and
initialization ah gradient descent on
this problem will actually converge to a
minimum l one norm solution
as opposed to minimum euclidean norm
solution
so here although we have minimum mel1
norm solution we again see some
connection to euclidean geometry because
of the gradient descent in a sense that
the l1 norm in the parameters in the
function space is
is related to euclidean norm in the
parameter space so the bias here again
brings us back to euclidean norms in the
parameter space
but unlike but like steeple's descent
like the implicit bias here also depends
on the step size so this
characterization holds only for minimum
uh infinitesimal step size and
infinitesimal initialization and it does
not hold more broadly for
any step size or initialization unlike
the first characterization for the
original parameterization
okay and in terms of proof we
essentially prove this by showing that
the updates for this algo this in this
case also lie in a low dimensional
manifold but in this case the manifold
is not
is not a linear manifold or rather an
affine manifold as a consequence you
need these infinitesimal step sizes and
other conditions for this theorem to
hold
so just to summarize uh what we saw was
first positive result where we connected
where we're able to cleanly connect
between optimization bias and geometry
for mirror descent and we saw a very
strong negative result where we were not
able to make this connection even under
some special
step sizes and special initializations
and we saw
we also studied like what happens with
the geometry induced by parameters and
one thing i didn't talk about today like
was
with what
which is which is the problem we started
studying which is of matrix
factorization so you can think of an
equivalent least squares problem in the
matrix space and there equivalent
parameterization for a full dimensional
matrix is a product of two matrices so
here is a matrix product and in this
case our initial experiment suggested
that doing gradient descent on this
objective with small initialization and
step size leads to minimum nuclear norm
solution and the follow-up work actually
proved it for some special case
measurements ah
but
again this was our original work and the
corollary of it was the element wise
product result i previously described
um so
follow-up of these works is like we we
we have a very recent result which nadi
talked about yesterday where you can
show that for this element wise product
parameterization the scale of the
initialization is a very plays a very
crucial role in particular in the in our
earlier work we showed that when
initialization goes to 0 you get this
minimum l1 norm solution
in the more recent work we show that as
you increase initialization the implicit
regularization interpolates between
l one norm and l two norm but this
interpolation does not exactly match the
regularization path which we would
expect from
purely
extending the geometry argument
and also another point against like
exactly relating to the geometry was
done by uh sanjeev nadav and
their colleagues where they show that
even if uh considering instead of
writing the
vector as a product of two vectors if i
if we continue to write it as a product
of k vectors and look at what happens
when initialization goes to zero
we still continue to get a minimum l1
norm solution and that bias is not
relating to
minimizing the l2 norm of these product
vectors so here again we see a mismatch
between
what the real inductive bias is versus
what the geometry would immediately
suggest
so in summary like we we see that for
squared loss there is uh there are some
places where there is a very clear
connection and we would
between geometry of the updates and the
geometry of the algor
the optimization bias but there are also
clear examples where that connection
breaks pretty drastically and ah at this
point i we don't have a clear picture
and i don't know how to get a clear
picture of how exactly like the
connection
works and where it breaks so right at
this point so this is just a summary of
what
i just talked about and ah
so
in particular in many cases the
initialization and step size crucially
affect the optimization bias when when
we are dealing with square laws and a
precise characterization is like elusive
even for simple linear models so let
alone for more complicated models and we
see that we need more tools to analyze
the nature of optimization bias
so
much of this work was done quite earlier
and during this time in various points
of space-time continuum like a few
people
like
were thinking why why are we not looking
at logistic laws like most neural
networks we use in practice actually
work with logistic laws or at least like
the most reproducible words and
as a result we started looking at
logistic laws as a
i mean implicit bias in the logistic
loss setting and that would be like the
part two of my talk and we'll see that
like the main takeaway of putting these
two in a juxtaposition way was to see
that like the nature of the optimization
bias as a consequence anything we can
say about
um
algorithmic regularization or
generalization from
inductive buyers from our
optimization algorithms will be very
different if we consider classification
losses versus uh regression losses and
here by classification losses i would
very explicitly mean like logistic type
losses i'll explain what it is in a bit
so let's look at
classification problems where we'll
consider simple binary classification
problem two sets of data and again we'll
stick with linear models so the data
sets are linearly separable
and uh we are minimizing some loss
between the linear predictor and uh
and and the label in particular we'll be
looking at uh these expo strictly
decaying laws with exponential tail
and examples are like two common
examples are logistic loss and x plus
for most of my results will be stated in
terms of x plus because that's easier to
analyze mathematically and
but ah
i mean in the regimes we are analyzing
these two losses
most of the results can be extended to
logistic laws too so you can pick
whichever loss is more convenient for
you to think about
but the key property which we use is
that these are both strictly decaying
losses so in other words if i have a
separable data set
the loss
the minimum of this loss is never
attained
in other words i can i can just keep
decreasing the loss
the argument of this loss does not exist
for any finite value of w in other words
i have to make the norm of w infinite in
order to make this law zero
right so
as a result if i even though these are
convex problems these lead to convex
problems if i just run gradient descent
on these problems the iterates will
diverge in no and you will never
converge so you cannot ask what does
gradient doesn't converge to for this
problem
but
even for these problems what we really
care about is not what gradient design
converges to but what is what separator
does gradient descent return so in other
words what we really care about is not
the exact value of the nitrates but ah
the direction of the
iterates because for classification
problems we only care about like the
sign of this inner product so for that
only like the direction matters and in
particular different separating
directions are different classifiers
different global minimizers of this
problem
and we can ask which classifier
direction or direction does gradient
design converge to
and one of the early results for this uh
is essentially saying that gradient
design will converge to a
maximum margin solution which is maximum
euclidean non-margin solution ah and the
interesting thing here is that unlikely
unlike um
squared loss setting here we get a
characterization which is step
independent of step size and
initialization
because as long as you start with any
finite initialization and finite step
size you will always converge to this
initialization independent
characterization asymptotically
and uh just to give some historical
context this this result was previously
known for
l1 max margin from boosting so if you
did coordinate descent on this linearly
separable problem uh it was shown by
muchus chalgarsky a few years back that
you will converge from l one max margin
solution and in fact in a follow-up work
uh
they also prove uh matures and students
z-way actually prove convergence of
i mean this kind of gradient decentral
convergence to max margin solutions even
with
stochastic gradient descent kind of
algorithms
and the the reason this happens is i
mean the proof behind these kind of ah
results is also quite simple which is
again we can write down what the
gradients are and we can see that
immediately like ah
the factors which
the data points which are closest to a
decision boundary contribute the maximum
amount in uh
in the in the gradients so when we keep
summing these gradients we see that the
data points which are closest to the
decision boundary will dominate the sum
as a consequence your final predictor
can be are predominantly explained by
the closest data points which are
support vectors
and that is a rough idea behind uh the
proof of these methods
uh but in terms of like we started with
under trying to understand it for
general geometries
and now when we looked at the same
algorithm
for a different loss function uh we see
that for steepest reason where for
squared loss we couldn't give any form
of concrete characterization we see that
for general norms and for steeper season
with respect to general norms and
exponential laws we can give a very
clean characterization
that relates to the geometry of the
steepest descent updates and
and the implicit bias from the algorithm
in particular we can show that you
converge to a max margin solution with
rest which minimizes the
the norm corresponding to the steepest
descent updates
and similarly we can say ask what
happens for mirror descent a natural
thing would be to say that you convert
to something which maximizes minimizes
the the corresponding mirror design
potential subject to margin constraints
but uh even if you stare at it for a
little bit you see that this doesn't
make this the right hand side does not
make much sense because for general
potential this is not a homogeneous
model
for general potentials like psi of w is
not homogeneous so a margin of 1 is
nothing special
so i might put 2 and i get a different
answer so in some sense we don't get
expect to
i mean this this is no special solution
unlike for unlike when the potential is
a norm
so actually our
we have some results that for certain
kind of potentials you can show that
what mirror doesn't converges to is
actually a limit of this margin path so
you you
you compute what is the argument of this
problem where uh the margin is greater
than gamma and look at the limit when
gamma goes to infinity
and that is that is that this
characterization at least holds for
certain types of uh potential functions
we can think of
okay now going to in the last five
minutes or so like going into what we
can say about parameter uh geometry
induced by parameter different
parameters we specifically looked at
again again different parameters induced
by linear networks so linear networks is
just a very complicated way of writing a
linear model where you pass it through a
bunch of linear
compositions
and this is an useful structure because
different constraints on these
compositions actually lead to different
architectures in particular we will be
interested in looking at fully connected
networks where there are no constraints
on these matrices and convolution
networks where each of these individual
compositions are restricted to be full
dimensional convolutions
and in both these cases we will be
looking at again x plus and these
results can be generalized to logistic
loss
ah
the key thing to note is like all
networks whether it's convolution or
fully connected linear networks
eventually
implement only linear classifiers as a
consequence this optimization problem is
equivalent to just simple logistic
regression
but the question we again ask is like
which classifier how does different
parameterization affect like
different
leaders to different solutions
and uh we we could solve it for two
special cases and generalize it to some
instrument the two special cases were
like linear fully connected networks in
which case we can we can show under
caveats of assumptions that uh for any
depth in respect of number of layers you
add the solution you converge to is
actually a minimum euclidean solution
so this is the same solution we get from
logistic regression
and ah
this is the same solution we get from
logistic regression so we we haven't
changed anything by
adding layers
whereas when we go to convolution
architecture
we get some very interesting biases
specifically again under
many assumptions we we show that the
convolution architecture
leads to solution which promotes
sparsity in the frequency domain in
particular if we have a two layer
convolution network that is one
convolution layer and then connecting
everything ah we get a solution which is
minimum minimizing the l one norm of the
fourier coefficients of the final linear
predictor subject to margin constraints
so l one norm is sparsity and using so
this in some sense induces sparsity in
the frequency fourier domain at least
and
for larger uh for more than uh two
convolution layers we have a
characterization which is not quite as
strong we don't say that you converge to
a minimizer of some optimization problem
but you show that you converge to
stationary points of some of some
sparsity and using panel penalized
problem
and the key thing here is that the bias
here is not simply because of
convolution architecture or gradient
descent alone but it is the combination
of the architecture and algorithm which
introduces this this special type of
bias
because i'm running out of time i'm
going to
quickly go over the theorem details but
not in too much detail
so the main question we we try to answer
in all these work is to understand which
classifier does gradient descent return
when you have multiple classifiers
in a linearly separable data
data setting
ah related question is that the
optimization objective becomes non
convex the moment we change the
parameterization and most of these cases
it is non-convex the question is does it
does gradient doesn't really even
minimize the objective even that's not
clear and another more complicated
question is like these problems don't
have finite minimizers and as a
consequence the direction of the
iterates will diverge
but we also want to
we are giving characterization on what
the normalized direction is
and it's not clear if the direction
itself converges and
we weren't able to prove it so we made
these as assumption and focused on the
main
work but actually a follow-up work by ah
z-way and matches actually
prove this result for linear fully
connected networks without these
assumption
and
without these assumptions on
convergences and so there is a much
cleaner result of at least the fully
connected network
ah so generalizing this these were the
two special cases we were able to prove
uh and you can also generalize the
setting to
ah more general generic setting where
you are looking at linear models where
the mapping from parameters to the
linear function is a homogeneous mapping
homogeneous mapping essentially says
that if you scale the parameters by
alpha the function gets scaled by some
function of alpha some scalar function
of alpha and in all these cases under
similar assumptions we were able to show
that show a result which is in some
sense more general some sense less
general it's more general because we are
able to show it for general homogeneous
models but less general because we are
able to show convergence to stationary
points in parameter space we don't say
anything about what happens in the
function space
all our previous results were on what
happens in the linear function space
but
this results in particular is what
happens in the parameter space
but this gives us at least one starting
point where we can now start to analyze
what the induced bias is we see that for
all of these family of models you your
induced bias is l two norm in the
parameter space and but as we saw
earlier a simple induced bias in the
parameter space can lead to very
complicated biases in the function space
and now we can focus on understanding
what these complicated advisors are for
different architectures and so on uh
in in yet another series of follow up
work uh actually there is a much
stronger version of all these results
where they can show
this theorem essentially without many of
the assumptions and also for general
homogeneous models
uh
so yeah so
second last step before concluding
flight okay so they're also able to show
it for uh general homogeneous models uh
which not necessarily linear and in all
these cases again we see that there is a
bias towards minimizing l2 norm
again with the caveat that these are
stationary points in the parameter space
and these need not translate to in
general stationary points in the
function space
and that part of the link is still
missing from all these results
so just to summarize i i just went over
a bunch of results for exponential tail
losses but how do i connect it to the
earlier work i mean the goal of this was
to show that the nature of the
optimization bias is indeed very
different from squared loss so in
particular for exponential losses you
have this infinite arc length like from
where you start where you end up is like
almost infinite distance away so you you
often get much cleaner or much simpler
asymptotic results
so not only is the nature of the bias
different where we get max margin versus
minimum solution but often and with
external losses in the asymptotics we
consider we get
initialization and step size independent
characterization and uh we are also like
uh getting characterizations for many
complicated models which were not like
previously
which we were not able to analyze in the
square law setting but more importantly
we were
we were able to concretely establish
biases which are not necessarily rkhs
norms uh
and connecting it to reconciling this
this line of results with the recent
line of ntk results uh would be an
interesting future work we are working
on
and just to conclude like uh
we've been working with this for this is
that the role of optimization in ml at
this point extends beyond reaching any
global minimizer and in today's talk i
explicitly talked about how the geometry
of the updates as well as the geometry
of the parameters determine the nature
of the optimization bias and also how
the nature of the optimization bias
differs between classification and
regression losses yeah thank you for
your attention
[Applause]
on the homogeneous models
so can you also apply it to like the
exponent being zero which would apply to
batch form network
so can you for the homogeneous yeah
models does that include
the exponent being zero so that it
includes like batch normalization
uh no at this point like
yeah even if you add a bias term it is
not homogeneous and we don't know the
result
like in the layers if you had a bias
it wouldn't be homogeneous model and we
can't well with batterization the bias
doesn't matter at all
no uh the short answer is i don't think
those results extend to when you use
batch normalization so like what is the
exponent on the homogeneous so you had
an alpha to the newth power what is nu
in the new is anything greater than one
oh okay so it doesn't include zero
uh yeah i don't think it yeah you cannot
work with zero yeah
okay uh
i i have to check with zero but like
yeah okay we need something in here
all right for the second talk we have
alexander madrid from mit
yeah and thanks
yeah thanks for the invitation it's fun
to be in redmond especially in the
summer
uh
yes
so yes so
this works about geometry deep learning
and kind of it's not in the title but
theorems so what i will give you today
is geometry and deep learning not so
much theorems uh there are actually
theorems behind it but i realize that it
will be more fun to kind of change a bit
the format so you know
we can learn something a bit different
okay so first of all the most important
thing this is based on joint work with
this great people
and you know
essentially
most of the price for this work goes to
to this to them and some of them are
already are already here so you can
actually ask them questions about what's
going on if you want to okay cool
so
i guess you know it's good to finally
since the second second day of the
workshop it's good to think about you
know why are we here in particular well
i guess we are here because of this you
know everyone now loves deep learning so
why do we love deep learning well first
of all it actually made an incredible
progress on some of the key benchmark in
machine learning so things we couldn't
have done 10 years ago suddenly we can
just do very easily
okay we also love deep learning because
it seems to be enabling us to have all
these really cool applications and kind
of you know changing the way things work
in the reward so i guess self-driving
cars is one of the most kind of
inspiring use of of deep learning that
we can imagine
so this is all great
also like kind of from the more machine
learning point of view is again like
this we have this all very interesting
generalization results that kind of we
can really kind of outperform like what
the classical methods were able to do by
just using deep learning we still don't
fully understand why it works but it
definitely works reliably
and the other maybe a less widespread
but but essentially kind of very
interesting property of uh
of deep learning is that kind of from
the geometric point of view the way one
can see it as a kind of a way of you
know taking the input data
which essentially has some kind of
intrinsic
you know intrinsic semantic structure
and kind of changing the geometry of the
data into well this representation
layers okay via all these layers that
have kind of more and more complex
features
that kind of ends up with this very nice
euclidean kind of geometry that seems to
reflect well you know the original
geometry of the data okay so somehow the
structure that we kind of are able to
get this intrinsic geometry and change
it into the l2 geometries geometry we
actually like is something that actually
plays very powerfully on kind of a more
advanced uses of deep learning
okay
great so this is why we
love deep learning but
i must say that this love is not an easy
love okay because there are some
problems
okay so in particular as much as
self-driving cars are a thing you know
you and they work most of the times
sometimes they don't okay so here's just
a video of tesla you know of a tesla car
in the you know driver's assistant mode
which essentially decides to run into a
divider and the driver has to take over
i think eric has another story to share
in this you know similar vein so you see
it's no most of the times things work
well but sometimes they can go very
badly
the other thing is that of course you
know as much as we tend to do well on on
you know on most of the inputs with our
classification there are some inputs
that we get wrong so here is an input
that is from the imagenet classification
task in which correct label is insect
but for some reason
you know the classifier claims this is a
dog
again not fun
finally you know even if you look at
this kind of you know geometry kind of
you know this geometry embedding of like
taking the semantic distance and
changing it into the l2 distance we
actually if you look very close your
eyes are glitches so it's not hard to
find two inputs that like look very
differently semantically but actually
mapped to essentially the same
representation
so something is not exactly right
okay
so
what's going on okay so where is this
you know why do we see this glitches
and kind of
one of the kind of key problems here is
this kind of
unusual brittleness of our machine
learning solutions okay and one of the
flagship demonstration of this is sort
of this you know phenomena of adversary
perturbations in which what happens is
that i can take an
input image that is classified correctly
with high confidence
i can add to it just a bit of a noise
not a random noise but like specifically
chosen noise and then i get a picture
which you know looks exactly to us as
the previous picture but somehow the
prediction of the classifier changes
dramatically
okay this is so what is called those
obviously examples
and kind of this is you know so what
many people including me were working on
recently and kind of we suddenly started
to make sense of it okay so essentially
what we started to do realized okay the
kind of root of the problem is that
maybe the notion of generalization we
were looking for was not the right one
essentially if you just look at the
classic kind of minimizing of the
population risk essentially like this
population risk does not tell us
anything about robustness to
perturbation so maybe the way to do it
is essentially introduce like look for a
different notion of generalization this
adversarial bargainization in which we
kind of ask for kind of our prediction
being do good in expectation but being
robust to some set of perturbation
okay and this is like you know this is a
very this is kind of a very kind of
quick overview of what was happening for
the last year or so and is still
happening
but i would say and this may be a bit
controversial that you kind of once you
understood that this is at least this is
something that will make things a bit
better
we kind of succeed in getting there
again we are definitely not there but
definitely we can say that first
successes are there
uh we have a party after that i'm happy
to answer all of this question it's a
great question like what you should
choose this like what is actually
extremely important and there is no one
answer to it it's domain dependent but
there is even more to be said i'm happy
to continue this conversation apparently
jerry has to keep me on time so i want
to help him do that
so
okay
so it's great we have this kind of you
know this new regime of machine learning
in which like i was like you can view
this especially learning via adverse
highly robust lens when we think about
adversarialization
and then we learn things about it so one
thing we learned that even though we
seem to be getting some kind of robust
models
training this one is harder and these
models actually need to be more complex
okay the other things that we might be
we might discover is actually there
seems to be a price of being robust
essentially the models that are robust
they actually might need to be less
accurate in the classical notion of
accuracy meaning in this kind of
standard notion of generalization
and this seems to not be just that we
cannot get best of both worlds actually
provably sometimes you can show that you
cannot get both like the best of the
both words
and also we actually also realized that
you might actually need more training
data
to get an adversarially robust
classifier as opposed to just a you know
standard like and
that generalizes in the standard way
okay
so this is kind of the things that we
discovered and but this is kind of very
descriptive we just say this is how
things are
and somehow what is kind of was to me
very much unsatisfying is that yes we
know how and what
but we don't really know why okay so we
actually know how this robust machine
learning seems to look like but it's not
clear exactly like why these things look
the way they did
okay so in particular some of this
question that we kind of still did not
really answer is like why adversely
perturbation exists and are why they are
so widespread okay and why it's so easy
for every input like seemingly for every
input to find the perturbation that kind
of that will you know that will fool it
if the model is not robust
i know why this perturbations into
transfer so what is kind of quite
puzzling is not only that for a given
model i can find it and give an input i
can find a perturbation that will fool
this model on this input you can
actually reuse the same perturbation and
it seems to work for many models in fact
you can even get a perturbations that
tends to work for many inputs and for
many models
and this is kind of surprising okay if
this is kind of this is something that
definitely i had hard trouble
like i had trouble actually explaining
and then like now even we have some
techniques now that kind of seem to work
to get us robustness but you know even
though we have intuition why they work
it's not
you know kind of convincing you know why
they work
and you know so this is like this is the
kind of classic technique for for doing
this the robust training also there is
recently there is a work on randomized
moving which also seems to be an
effective technique and again there is
some intuition why it works but i would
not say that this is kind of you know
like fully end-to-end convincing
convincing or like full full full
explanation okay so this is the question
and today i want to try to give you some
partial answers always partial answers
to these questions
okay and let's start with the first
question so why adversarial
perturbations exist and why they are so
widespread okay so this is the question
so why are models so brittle if we don't
like put some care into making them not
brittle
and of course this is a question that
you know i'm definitely not the first
one to study there is like even people
in this in in this room like already
provide this some you know some some
like some potential answers to it and i
would say that they tend to fall in the
following category it's either they say
okay this is you know because our models
are so so because our data and our
models are so heavy dimensional that's
kind of the glitches that you will be
getting
the other people say this is about like
statistical fluctuations in our data
that this is again some kind of glitch
that you know that comes from the fact
that we are sampling some distribution
other people say you know this is just
exactly like we are aiming for average
case performance and now we are asking
about worst case performance this can
kind of never work generically
there are also people who claim that
this is kind of some kind of you know a
punishment for using you know deep
learning essentially the way we train
our model is not the right way to train
and kind of this is you know and this is
what you get if you do it not in the way
that it should be done
okay so somehow there's many
explanations
and kind of i would say that the
unifying the theme there for most of
them is that kind of the viewers for
example is aberrations like in some ways
if we did our learning the right way
they should mostly go away okay somehow
like the fact that we see this example
is just uh this is a evidence that there
is something that we do wrong currently
with the machine learning
okay
so that's the theme
so okay so let's think about it so first
of all let's actually ask a question
that we might not have asked because
it's intuitively obvious to us is why
are adversarial perturbations bad okay
so what is upsetting about them well
what is upsetting about themselves like
here so here we have a beautiful dog
over here that we recognize as dog and
also our network organizes a dog so
that's exactly how we want our walls to
be
but then there's this weird thing that
we are adding this kind of meaningless
perturbation to it
and suddenly this dog from being a
perfectly nice dog somehow for our
mothers become a cut
and this is clearly like the upsetting
part about you know about adversarial
example like somehow that a kind of a
meaningless uh like change to the data
seems to lead to semantic change in the
data
okay
so yeah so this is the upsetting thing
but a kind of the point i want to make
here is and that will be a point that
will turn out to be very important is
that kind of this is upsetting
kind of only if you are human okay
because that's how you if you look at
this
that's how you know that's how that's
how you you judge it it's also upsetting
if you're a dog
no it's not clear like we will get back
to that that's a good question i think
dog would be upset we should probably
have some study about that but they
might be actually less upset than we are
and you will see what i mean by that uh
but that's a good question
uh
so okay so let's think about it a bit
deeper so yeah let's think about this
kind of the most important task in
machine learning you know distinguishing
cats and dogs
so kind of
again with your humans we know how to
solve this task yes like what we look we
look at some kind of you know features
like snout or ears and this is kind of
looking at these things we can clearly
tell is it the cat or is the dog and
that's what we really mean when we think
about distinguishing cuts from dogs
okay
so that's perfectly fine that's how we
solve these problems but kind of i think
the thing to realize that maybe you know
as much as this makes sense to us as
humans it's not clear at all that this
is you know this makes sense to networks
to our neural network as well
after all such a neural network to it
this image is meaningless to it is just
a collection of numbers okay that's just
a vector that's all that it's really
seeing
so so this image is has no meaning no no
no interesting meaning and also the
class dog is meaningless to it it's just
not done has no concept of dog to which
is just a string that is supposed to
correlate with some of the kind of
numbers in this you know in this vector
and its only goal is not to learn what
adobe is or what a cut is it has only
one simple goal is just to maximize its
text test accuracy so when we run the
statistical test during tests you know
during testing our model it just wants
the accuracy to be as high as possible
in whatever ways it can do it
so somehow if you realize that you
realize that like if you look at this
cad versus dog
question from the neural network
perspective maybe this is not the right
thing to have in mind maybe what you
should think about is this kind of much
more abstract question of recognizing
you know there are inputs that are like
belong to the to a class tab
and inputs that belong to the class talk
what is tap and talk i have no idea what
these things mean i have no idea but now
you're exactly the same state as your
neural network there is no
like prior known prior knowledge in what
you are doing you know when you are
facing this task
and then you know when this cannot
observe enough inputs you might realize
that oh actually like this rectangle
appearing like this correlates with you
know this this you know input belonging
to cluster
this rectangle or correspond like you
know showing up here corresponds to the
class talk and that's how you would
solve this task both as a human and as a
neural network okay so now we are under
the same on the same grounding
so if you think about this question like
again why you know why are the cell
exams are upsetting so again for humans
we know why things are upsetting here
but if you look from the the you know
from the point of view of neural network
it just says okay there was some input
from class tap
then there was some perturbation added
over here
and then i had something from class talk
and the you know the
the the kind of the annoying thing here
was supposed to be the fact that this
perturbation is meaningless
okay
but here is the question
so are actually this perturbation
meaningless okay let's think about this
in particular let's think about the
following simple experiment
so what i will do is i will take my kind
of training set for like cl like dogs
versus cut you know a problem
and what i will do is i actually will
create a second training set so what i
will do is essentially i will take every
input
like corresponding to a dog
i will find an adversarial perturbation
that convinces my model that it is a cut
and then i will actually change the
label and i will claim this is an this
is an instance of a cut and i will do
the same thing to every input of
of a cut in my you know in my in my in
my training original training set
okay
so this way
i essentially got a new training set
okay
and then what i will do is i will
actually train a new model on this
training set
and then i will test it but i will test
it on the original test set
okay so let's think what actually
happened
so what i do is i am training my new
model
on a data set that to a human looks like
a totally mislabeled like not a single
cat is labeled as a cat and not a single
dog is labeled as dog
okay
that's the training set still for some
magical reason i expected to when i show
it you know the images from the test set
i expected to know that you know that
how a dog and how a cat looks like i
actually wanted to like if there's a
picture of a cat it should say cat if
there's a picture of a dog it should be
a dog
so
what do we think what do you think will
happen when i do this experiment
sorry
it'll be like you're training without
the fertilization yes otherwise it
wouldn't be it will be surprising so
what we kind of might be like the first
intuition would be to expect that you
will completely get zero percent
essentially you will name every cat the
dog and every dog cut but if you
actually do it you will end up having a
non-trivial accuracy on this original
task so if you do it on the like cast
versus dog cfar question you'll get 78
accuracy
again even though i've never shown you
seemingly a dog labeled as a dog a cat
labeled as a cat
okay
what's going on
so
kind of the hypothesis or kind of
statement that we have here is that
maybe so maybe the problem with like our
mindset like what makes this kind of
experiment confusing is maybe there was
like the the one assumption that we were
making was that the perturbations are
meaningless
but what if they are not meaningless so
what do i mean by that so think about
the following conceptual picture
in which kind of we have two kind of
predictive features in our data there
are the ones that i would call robust so
these are the the features that kind of
patterns that cannot be altered by
applying the small perturbations to your
data
so in particular all the things that we
as humans would use to distinguish
between cats and dogs kind of would
belong to this
but then
there is also another set of patterns in
data like it corresponds to features
that we call non-robust so these are
patterns that can actually be flipped by
applying only a small perturbation of
the data
but you know this these features are
also by themselves like if they're not
perturbed they're also predictive of the
correct label
okay and essentially
when you are this you know a deep like
this machine learning model and you try
to just maximize the accuracy
both kinds of features are totally fine
to you right like essentially anything
that allows you to predict well the
label is just like you know is a valid
feature to you
and actually it turns out that this
non-robust features tend to be often
very good predictors
of you know of of the correct label i'm
not saying that individual features i'm
saying that as a collection of like
you know of the features like in total
they seem to have very very good
predictive power of what the correct
label is
so now
if you know if they are good to get the
correct label and we just ask our models
to just get us you know good
predictiveness of the label well our
models tend to kind of tend to rely on
these features quite a bit
but if our predictions are ones that
rely on this you know on this features
quite a bit well when we start
perturbing them if you are able to just
flip them in the input that we present
to the model you know the model will
think that this is a different class
and essentially that's the kind of the
you know that's the statement that we
are trying to make here
okay so in particular looking back to
our simple experiments kind of what you
know what
what happened was just the following
that we kind of started from this
training set in which both the robust
and non-robust features kind of were
associated with the correct number uh
like reliable dog
but then when we created the second
training experiment the robust features
still kind of consistent with like what
we humans see as dogger cut but the
non-robust features by using inside
perturbations they actually flipped the
kind of non-robust features responding
to cut and dock to the opposite class
so when we did the labeling what will
happen is that the robot features what
now became misleading because they were
kind of indicating the the other class
but the non-robust features were
sufficient to get good generalization
because they were still exactly like you
know correlated with the right sign with
the dog versus versus cut question
okay
so essentially like and the crucial
thing is that this adversariation had to
flip this actually predictive feature in
the data
so yeah so essentially that's how you
know that's how we get the good test
accuracy because just kind of the since
the model like depends a lot on the
non-robust features since this signal is
correct it is still able to get the test
set like labeled correctly most of the
time
okay
so this is the so this is the kind of
statement
and this actually cement has quite a
number of implications okay so first of
all i think one important implication is
again something that we intuitively know
but maybe that's now it's more
contrast is that kind of again when we
approach our
vision tasks especially we have certain
priorities we have certain view how
models learn
and this might have nothing to do with
how mothers actually learn and that's
actually very important thing to keep in
mind yes just to test this
you i i know i think you already did it
but you can also do adversarial training
on the spiritual data set and then it
should be to confirm your hypothesis
that it's not like everything is going
to be flipped it's going to
detect darkest cotton i'm not sure what
exactly but like we did many of these
and again i want jerry to not have to
kick me out so after that but like we
did many things to try to like first you
know spoil this like you know kind of
disprove it and we couldn't
okay
so yeah and the point is these are the
equally valid classification methods and
you should know there should be no
expectation unless you do anything else
to kind of to that you know the model
uses one way or the other way to solve
the task it just wants to solve the task
as stated in your objective function so
for instance you know these are examples
are in a sense a human phenomenon it's
not just something wrong with the
machine learning model just the kind of
we are asking for something and we don't
understand exactly what we are asking so
more of the specification of the task
than actual glitch in the machine
learning models
and essentially if you want to have in
particular interpretable models
you really have to think about this at
the training time because if your model
is actually
making predictions based on stuff that
you don't understand like you can't
comprehend
you never will make be able to make it
interpretable you first actually have to
force it to think like a human before
you can actually produce an
interpretation that human will
understand
okay and essentially
you know and essentially you know you
exactly you can kind of you can you can
view robustness it's kind of a way of
trying to put additional restriction
on the prior on like how your models
work to kind of to make them more
interpretable
okay so this is kind of the message now
what happens now well as i said i
promise you some answer or at least like
partial answers to questions okay so
this is actually gives you a new
perspective on a visual robustness
and also other questions too
so for instance like okay so one cool
capability that comes out comes out out
of this you know out of this kind of
understanding is that now we can do
something like a robustification of a
training set so we can take it can take
an original training set and create from
it
essentially a robustified data set
and what is fun about this data set is
that like when i'm on this data set i
can actually train in whatever way i
want like i can just use classic
training
and i'm still getting both standard and
robust accuracy so again this is not
exactly what happens but the idea here
is that you might be able to suppress or
filter out all of the non-robust
patterns in the data and then the only
way to classify this model you know kind
of correctly is to use robust features
and if you are only doing classification
using robust features then you are
robust by definition
how do you get the investment
essentially what you do is okay
i i will tell you after like at the
party but like the point is that you are
using a robust model to essentially ask
you to synthesize a version of the
original input that kind of you know
only has the feature that make it
believe that this is like a frog or
something else and that's the image that
you get
while i enjoy kicking you out you're
like five minutes so you don't have to
be too rough
oh you don't know how much more i have
but thank you um
okay
so this is the new uh so this is new
capability i can you can kind of
manipulate these features and kind of
filter out
a a filter out these features
and in particular this is again this
this data set is contrary example to a
statement that oh we have advertised
examples like this you know essentially
like
we have vulnerability to the examples uh
just because we are using bathroom sgd
or resins or whatever essentially you
can train on this model in whatever
whatever way you want and you will still
get robust classifier so essentially
like so again this of course factors can
have an impact but they alone will not
be responsible for robustness you can
like here there's no way to get
non-robust like vulnerable models out of
this because essentially these
non-robust features are are gone so it's
not about just how we train
okay so there are other consequences
that are kind of quite quite fine fun so
in particular the transferability now
kind of makes sense because features are
a property of data set not a model so
essentially like any model trained on
them will turn well we'll
is likely to use the same robust
features for prediction and that's why
you know changing these features will
actually lead to misclassification
also like why
like the robust training is is effective
i know i did not explain what robust
training is but the point is that if you
think if you know what it is or if you
learn what it is you realize that
essentially what is kind of the way to
view it is that what it's trying to do
is trying to actually make all the
non-robust patterns the data be useless
for prediction essentially you always
kind of pound your model the moment it
kind of tries to make a prediction based
on some non-robust patterns you kind of
realize that and you kind of like flip
it to kind of to penalize your model for
using anything that is not robust
similarly for randomized moving which is
as a way of adding like
appropriately modulated noise to your
inputs to get robustness you can view it
as just kind of trying to overwhelm all
by noise all the features that kind of
are non-robust to the perturbation class
that you want to be robust to
okay again i can go more more into this
but kind of the point i particularly
like is just this connection between the
robustness and data efficiency so this
is something that we already talked
about that kind of learning robust like
robot machine learning seems to behave
differently than the standard machine
learning
and now it all makes sense since robots
models can only leverage robust features
they are somehow handicapped because of
that right so you know even though none
of that features do help with
standardization we don't allow the model
to use them so as a result you will need
to get more data to get a given accuracy
and you will also in general maybe you
know without using non-robust non-robust
features you will never get the kind of
top accuracy that would be possible if
you just have to use only robust
features alone
and so that's kind of the that's kind of
the explanation of some of the facts
that we observe in practice and in kind
of we could show in toy models
but kind of the question that i actually
like to ask is kind of is the fact
that like standard models leverage the
non-robust features is it actually even
a good thing like again of course it's
not a good thing if you have vastness
but even if you don't care about
robustness like what using non-robust
features actually mean
okay and you know this is essentially
like sorry i i'm clicking too much uh so
kind of the sorry what's happening here
yeah i think i am
oh yeah
clearly clearly using uh like clicker is
is above my power like above my pay
grant
so kind of the thing is that maybe kind
of yeah we can get the superhuman
performance but we only are getting it
because we are using some patterns in
the data that is not what is a part of
the task that we actually want to solve
okay
and you know there is some nice
theoretical model as well that you can
kind of play with to see some of these
effects so for instance you can see that
if you think about mox like maximum
likelihood gaussian classification
essentially like you know if you go from
what is the right decision boundary for
standard task and you're starting up you
start adding some robustness aspects you
realize that the actual answer will kind
of shift like what you like your
estimators of like kind of like how to
classify in a robust way will actually
be very different to how the kind of
standard you know standard classifier
would look like again there are some
theorems in the paper but like the
things to observe are the one of them is
that somehow here we have two directions
we have kind of the robust direction in
which kind of you know large changes
you know kind of large changes in the l2
norm do not lead much to the kind of
changes in classification and then i
didn't know about the direction in which
kind of small changes in the l2 norm
might actually you know lead to big
changes in the classification and
clearly if you want to have maximum the
best accuracy you need to use like this
you need to attune to this kind of
different geometry in different
direction but when you want to have
robustness you actually have to forego
this statement and similarly what is
also cool is kind of if you think about
the greeting direction essentially you
ask yourself i am a data point and i
want you to to get you the closest to
the kind of data point that you know
that um
the data point that is kind of from a
different class
kind of if you do standard models you
will kind of go
somewhere of the i would say manifold
even though this is like
really like using too strong of a world
but as you are getting more robust
actually this direction kind of it
becomes more like you go from the center
of one cluster to the center of the
other cluster
okay
so this is kind of what we understand
about robust number of features now the
cool part which i will do in the last
you know whatever time i have left is to
show okay
so if we kind of have this inclination
that maybe non-robust features is not
something you would like to depend
anyway even if you don't care about
robustness so what happens if you look
at the models that are robust from the
point of view of like deep learning and
different applications so one thing you
realize is that actually the models just
by being robust they become more human
aligned okay so one quick way to do this
is just to look at kind of silencing
maps as your inputs so if you do like
essentially like what you do is you just
have this heat map for every pixel it
just says how influential this pixel is
in in the making this this this this
picture be classified as dog if you do
standard model you get things like that
which are kind of
however if you do it to robust models
you are getting things like this for
free
okay so essentially robot robustness
acts as a prior it kind of enforces like
using meaningful features
and then what happens is also if you go
look at the representations then
actually suddenly they start to make
like behave like this geometric
embedding starts to behave the way you
would like it to be so essentially like
it's we could not find two inputs that
have similar presentation but are very
different in semantic ways like it seems
that now you are kind of fixing this you
know these problems with that and when
you do that well a lot of cool stuff is
happening so i'm sure many of you have
seen guns and all these cool
interpolations that you can do with them
well you know we can do the same things
actually we can do more in some ways and
you can do it in a way way simpler way
than how guns go about it essentially
everything that we do is just we just
take robust representation and we apply
some the you know completely the most
obvious
you know most obvious ways optimization
there is no regularization no post
processing no priors
and you are fully faithful to the model
so we can do things like interpolation
of the input so essentially you know we
just have seen some interpolation
symmetry integration of the input before
but now you can just like the thing that
they don't tell you is that they
actually have to find these trajectories
in the gun they just like it's really
like they have to be extracted from the
from the from the gun here i just take
any two inputs and i can just get
interpolation right away in a very easy
way
okay the other thing is that kind of
like direct feature visualization
essentially like you can view of for
every for every neuron
you can view kind of you can you can
identify that they correspond to
something important you can do like cool
stuff like adding stripes to the you
know like once you know what the is this
the stripe neuro
the stripe neuron you can add it
and you can also do stuff like if you
remember the mislay the mislabeled input
over here we didn't know why the model
claims this is a dog if this was an
insect what you can do you can enhance
the features that
that kind of inform the prediction over
here and when you enhance them you
realize that actually this part looks
like a dog like a dog picture okay so
essentially and you know that you know
like imagenet models they like to see
dogs because there's many dogs in the
data set and that's what they are
actually hallucinating over here
okay
and the other thing this is beautiful
picture everyone wants to see the
beautiful picture come on
so
you can get a very simple like
generative models like really out of the
box in a very simple way like this is
something that before like two years ago
would be state-of-the-art like gun based
stuff and you can get it just like for
free and very easily you can also get
you know like other cool gun
applications right away you can even do
things like manipulating kind of you
know your data set semantically you can
make a picture of a dog be more like a
cat and so on and so on
you can even do things like you can just
take an image and if you know the face
up you can do you know you can play with
this kind of stuff you can kind of
change the properties of this of the
image in the semantic way again
everything is very simple you can
actually play with this demo yourself
it's over there
and that's essentially all i have to say
so
i will not i will not get you through
that
i guess the point is that you know since
like i i really respect jerry
i just want to say that like kind of you
know we we started to care about
robustness because of the like safety
questions
but now what we understand is that these
questions are actually more about trying
to like essentially you should think
about adversary robustness as just a way
of imposing prior in our models some of
them are might be just because of safety
reason some of them might be actually
that this is the way to regularize our
models to kind of depend on the features
that we actually want them to depend as
opposed to the features that seem to be
kind of the right one for the model
which doesn't have any preference by
itself okay thank you
[Applause]
let's take questions offline all right
so for our final talk of the day we have
soledad villar from nyu
thank you
thank you very much for inviting me
um i want to talk about graph neural
networks which is a family of neural
networks that are used to
learn algorithms for combinatorial
optimization problems and combinatorial
problems uh this is in a similar idea to
nina's talk earlier today how to learn
algorithms from a family of parametrized
algorithms uh i'm gonna
introduce
what this class of graphic networks is
and in order to do that i'm going to
motivate it by
the example of clustering the stochastic
block model
and
as a motivation of how you define this
this class of algorithms and in
particular i'm gonna motivate this by
some results by andrea and emmanuel uh
just i'm gonna give you like a rough
introduction that it may not be 100
accurate but the idea is the following
um
the idea you
you have a graph sample from the
stochastic block model where
basically you have a graph where there's
two planted communities and you draw an
edge between two nodes in the same
community with probability p and across
communities with probability q with p is
greater than q let's say and then you
observe an instance of this of this
graph and you want to identify what the
communities are
so if you look at the adjacency of this
matrix it looks this form but then
if you reorder the the nodes so that
they actually belong to the first nodes
belong to the first community and the
second nodes belong to the second
community you obtain something like this
that reveals the community structure in
a way so actually if you look at the
expected value of this matrix and you
look at the second eigenvector then
then that reveals the community
structure and this is like inspected
values it's just a rank two matrix
however
and this spectrum method works really
well in dense case but when you are in
the sparse regime this doesn't work
anymore in particular
the spectrum doesn't concentrate very
well when the graphs are sparse and the
laplacian is not useful for clustering
but there are other methods that succeed
such as the semi-definite pronoun
however is not everything not everything
is lost for spectrum methods there are
some specific spectrum methods that you
can look at that come from the uh
statistical physics community that they
observe that actually these
spectral methods coming from normal
tracking operator from belief
propagation actually you look at the
eigen eigen spectrum of these matrices
and they reveal the community structure
so
and they also observe that
uh this this uh
these spectrum methods are in
correspondence with uh this hessian that
that is a
kind of like a regularized spectral uh
like regularized laplacian where you
depending on some parameter that depends
on what is the model for the stochastic
block model that p and q and n uh you
can construct this specific laplacian
and if you look at the eigen spectrum of
this laplacian then it actually
reveals the community structure all the
way up to the informatic theoretical
threshold
however
this
uh this is very unstable if you look at
the
uh at the
unstable with respect to model
specification so for instance if you
say like this this is a plot actually
from
under undress paper where they show that
there exists this
specific
perturbation where you select a few not
a few notes in your graph and you
produce very small clicks and then if
you if you do that then the spectrum
method doesn't work anymore but the
the semi-definite program is still
robust with respect to this perturbation
in the model
so
basically what we want to do with this
graph neural networks is for specific
combinatorial optimization problems we
want to generate robust spectral methods
for these problems to and see if we can
learn this and see how they perform
so
uh one
one way to
to think about this is you can think of
spectral methods just like an instance
of spectrum method you can write it as a
power method a power iteration and
just you choose some initialization and
then
you apply your matrix many times and you
can unroll that as a neural network by
just
applying
thinking of
each layer of your neural network to be
one
instance of your power method and
and then uh you want to learn how to
combine the operators of your graph in a
very in a good spectrum method so you
you can just say well i'm just for each
of my matrices i'm going to choose a
parameter theta that depends on like
these operators on the graph and then
this is just a like a power iteration
uh but then you we
like it was established yesterday that
overparametrization is good for for this
kind of optimization problems in
generalization and in optimization so
one can
over parameterize the setting and
uh
so this this data is just not a scalar
but you can make it to be a matrix and
you can learn an embedding of your
previous the an embedding of the output
of your previous layer for the next
layer
and uh so th this and you can make these
uh these parameters depend on what layer
you are so it's not a power iteration
anymore if you don't share the weights
and
and then uh
these are the trainable parameters of
your model and this is what it's called
well spectral gnn and also you can apply
it uh non-linearity at each of the
layers so this is this is the way the
spectral genomes are defined and this is
one of the ways of thinking how to
motivate these these these classes of
functions that we want to analyze
and
what is v what where does it lead
so m is an n by n matrix b is a vector
that lives in
n times d t where t is the is the layer
so it's you can think of it if you think
of it as
uh the all this dt equals one then it's
just a multiplication of a matrix times
a vector and this is a number but then
you can make this
uh just a small matrix and then you can
make this
times dt times dt plus one
does that make sense
so in particular this architecture does
not depend on the size of your of your
graph so you can train it for
a graph of size 100 and then test it in
size of size because basically you're
learning how to combine the operators of
your graph in an over parameterized way
yeah
um
also they extend this this definition to
consider also the line graph uh and well
like these
uh number operators number tracking
number results that are indexed by the
edges of the graph and other
other
graphs like the power graph etc and the
interesting property that this
architecture has is that if you apply a
permutation to your to your graph in
labels of the graph then that
permutation comes out it comes outside
and that's what you care about because
the labels on your graph are not an
intrinsic property you care to learn
something that does not depend on the
way i'm giving you the graph
and that's that's the important property
for this
and so in this paper by zendaya chen and
alicia and john bruno they apply this
idea to
the
stochastic blog model and
in particular for the for some specific
cases like in two communities and
i think in other other cases they showed
that uh empirically they can make it all
the way to the information
threshold using this line graph neural
network and they have some
theoretical results where they
use some simplifications on the model
and they can show that all the local
minima have some bounded laws with
respect to their model but i think that
there's a lot that can be improving in
this in that setting
and also uh
which extended this setting to so here
this is trained with the with the labels
of the model that you generated
so in particular this is supervised
learning you train it with
the known community structure for random
instances of your model but richie
extended this idea to unsupervised
setting
so she considers max cut on random
regular graphs and she
modifies this idea to like a version of
reinforcement learning and she shows
that it can perform
quite well
um another motivating example for this
specific
graph neural networks is um the
quadratic assignment problem where
basically one wants to learn how to
match these two graphs so in particular
you can write the query assignment
problem as this optimization and
this quadratic assignment has
graph matching as a particular instance
and also deciding whether two graphs are
isomorphic is deciding whether this
objective is equal to zero
also you can write uh the timeline
salesman problem as the matching between
a
matrix with the pairwise distance and a
cycle between the the a graph that is a
cycle
with this number of points
and
distances between matrix spaces
and you can also
think of
how you can apply this graph neural
network setting for this quadratic
assignment problem and basically if you
have two graphs you can
learn
an embedding for these graphs and then
you learn an embedding for the first
graph and
for the second graph and then you you
can
compute the outer product between these
two embeddings and you round that to a
permutation and you see and you do like
back propagation with respect to that
and
for specific models like random regular
graphs and erdos training graphs with
some planted noise
uh
we can
you can see how it performs and actually
these graphene networks can give you
something that is comparable with the
semi-definite program or even better in
some models
and you can also see how it performs
uh for
for traveling salesman problem okay this
is just like a motivated example
but these spectral gnns are not the only
formulation for graphene networks that
exist
there are other formulations for
graphene networks and actually there's a
very large literature on graph neural
networks very recently another way of
looking at graphene networks is as
message passing neural networks the idea
is that every node
has some information and then it
communicates with the neighbors sending
their information and aggregates
whatever they received and and update
their their
knowledge
these
this message passed in neural networks
are also satisfied satisfy this
essential property that if you apply a
permutation labels you obtain the same
permutation in the output
so or or
in particular
if you if you write it yeah that way and
and then a natural question about
um
what can you do with these graphene
networks
was
partially answered
in in this paper by
uh yura leshkovitch
and
stephanie chikelga in iclr 2019 where
they ask how powerful are graph neural
networks
and
and they ask how powerful are graph
neural networks by asking the question
of how good are they distinguishing
non-isomorphic graphs so basically given
your class of graph neural networks in
particular they studied this message
passing your networks
is there
like if you consider every function in
your class how how well can they perform
by solving this graph a supervision
problem
and what they show is actually that this
message passing neural networks are can
be as powerful as the wastewater lehman
test from 1968 which is a test based on
message passing and this test is also
equivalent to a linear parameter
relaxation of the quadratic assignment
problem
and
in particular if your initialization is
uh
the
null features of your graph
then
and these null features are
considered
let's say
do not have more information that
whatever you see in the graph then this
message passing networks cannot
distinguish between non-isomorphic
regular graph with the same degree so
they are not very powerful in that
setting
however
there is
another idea of looking at this
graph neural networks
and
this is some
work by jarrod lipman and his group and
also gabriel pedro and nicolas geriven
where they consider
a different class of graphene networks
that are not
the message passing new networks nor the
spectral neural networks that we
discussed just now
and basically what they say is if one
wants to consider all the linear
functions
from say k tensors to r
uh that are invariant with respect to
permutations then actually when these
linear functions are very easily
parameterized and the dimension of this
space
is
is well
it's very simple like if you consider
just the matrices uh all the
invariant functions from matrices to r
then the dimension of that space is two
because given two of diagonal elements
there exists a permutation that sends
one element to the next and given two
diagonal elements there exists one
permutation that sends one to the other
one
and in particular if you have k tensors
then the dimension of that space
is the bell number of k
which is which is actually the
number of ways to split uh an element of
k elements in subsets
that correspond to how do you match uh
what what kind of diagonal of diagonal
elements in that setting you match to
whatever else
and
so if you in particular this the
dimension of this space is does not
depend on n if n is large enough
right so these invariant functions are
very easily characterized and if you
look at equivalent functions then you
can just do a
trick and realize that it's actually the
same as looking at the valiant functions
with
double the tensor
and
and they show that if you construct
an invariant network that is constructed
by composition of linear invariant
networks with some activation functions
that can be really or sigmoid that um
then this this family of neural networks
universally approximate the space of
invariant functions and actually in the
in the sp in the paper will cover of
course
then show that the same thing happens
for equation functions
and um and the idea
is that they just approximate uh
invariant functions like polynomials and
using some distress and then they
they see that
uh they can write
polynomials with tensors basically as
linear functions in tensors
and
but in order to universally approximate
then you need to go to
a very high order tensors and the rates
of convergence are not known
so
so in particular how do you put all
these like graphene networks families
and ideas together so
uh what we did was just we just look at
the the graphics the graphics are more
facing question that um
this how powerful our graph new networks
paper looks at and the universal
approximation question are actually the
same thing which is is it's very simple
to see like you can think that
uh um you can
say that a class of function is a graph
isomorphism discriminating if given to
non-isomorphic graphs there exists a
function in your class that separates
them like it gives you a number in one
and a different number and the other one
and of course the class of functions
that we care about are invariant
then um
you can see that if you can universally
approximate of course you can solve
graph isomorphism
and if you if you have a family of
functions that is a
graph isomorphism discriminating then
you can construct a two layer object
neural network that can actually
universally approximate so looking at
this problem is equivalent to looking at
the other problem and you can use this
um
language to
to class to classify uh the different
classes of neural networks and different
classes of uh functions expressed in
this way in terms of how well they
perform at solving the graph isomorphism
so in particular
you can construct examples of uh
um
of graphs that cannot be
distinguished by the lp but can be
distinguished by
uh this j g embodied networks uh
this uh two layer embodied networks uh
that
liebman considers and also you can
construct examples that for example you
can look at other classes and functions
that are not neural networks like
semi-definite programs or spectrum
methods and see how well they they
perform at that and in particular you
can use for instance this this linear
invaliant networks
and add operations like you can multiply
the output of two layers
and obtain
functions that are more expressive than
the previous one
etc
and
so
this is uh
more or less all that i wanted to say
but
um
some interesting questions regarding to
this problem are
so how to connect the depths of the
architecture or the architecture of your
new networks with a class of graphs that
they can separate also this this
analysis of this optimization landscape
that tells you that the local minima are
gold in some way and how can you
ex write it in the case of these
specific gns
and something that i'm interested in and
i'm currently working on is the
connection of these
these invariant functions with the sum
of squares ideas the idea is that uh
there's this sum of squares paper uh
where they
show that for the problem of detecting
hidden structures
the existence of a like
some of squares proof that
one plant
that one graph comes from one one
planted mole or the other one
can be
written as some spectral method and
and these spectral methods are typically
non-explicit
and they
it's not obvious how it's not
obvious how you can write this as a
graph neural network but in particular
i believe that these spectral methods
should have this invariance property
and
how we learn them come with present this
way etcetera so
this is it thank you
[Applause]
i actually had a question about this
witness connection to that's how i
started are you in the regime where the
the spectral methods do work and you
just want to say whether or not like uh
you can express them in its framework or
is it like another setting so there's a
specific class of problems where they
show that the existence of a sum of
squares
is equivalent to the existence of a
spectral method but it's not a classical
spectrum method it's a specific
sound spectrum method of a specific form
where they they construct a matrix where
all the entries are polynomials they
should exist without such speeches right
they show in like the existence they
show the existence of such a matrix but
then it's not explicit and also
it's not known that it's invariant but
the fact that if you look at if if you
if you see that this pronoun is
alivarian then the search space of your
parameters would not depend on the size
of the crack
in the same sense that environment
polynomials you know depending on that
so
this is not done right
as far as as far as they can tell like
the certificates could be very different
for different sizes of the common sense
yes okay
other questions
so you gave at beginning this example of
robustness so there are other examples
that you have in mind where you know
this
for instance this uh power iteration
that you describe
application uh
i i don't know but i
uh i was taken in that specific
example but for instance for the quality
concern
it's not obvious that a good spectrum
cannot exist for any of these of these
models for instance if they if if the
money is trivial like you have a two
graphs that basically the existing
permutation and the graphs are not
like
like they have different spectrum i
think then yes but otherwise
there may not be a spectrometer in that
specific either
all right let's uh i think it's deeper
again
you